the lay is a quintessential part of
Hawaii a symbol stretching back to
ancient times but lay are not
one-size-fits-all and across the
Hawaiian Islands there are many lay
makers and many style of lei this is
bill char a legend in traditional
Hawaiian lei making the early people did
very simple leis
they weren't these gorgeous colorful
leis like this today this is just done
with ferns it's one object just braided
on itself a lot of them were very simple
like chili flake used for symbolic
purposes when you're making LA and it's
like a backbone your family ties and
you're adding each flower is sort of
like a person your cousin your sister
you add to your brother all along you're
wrapping on top of the stems that is the
backbone of your family and it just
keeps going on and on then you have your
leaf Cruise Lines would come in those
are the old days and people would come
and they would get their lives and it
was part of the tradition to stop in
Hawaii when you stopped you got a little
a
when tourists began coming to the
islands a stone style of lei called Kui
became popular and Chinatown was the
place to get them one of the many places
in Chinatown is called Cindy's lay and
flower shop it's been in business for 50
years in the very beginning there were
maybe like four four or five different
type of leis now you have like 40 40 or
more 50 years ago flowers are still
being made the same way needle and
string the flowers get delivered here
and we sort them out and we string them
the best we can who crafts so that it
looks natural open lei making is passed
down through family tradition and
continues to find new expression in the
next generation my tutu or grandmother
she was a pretty prolific lay maker in
Hawaii
I helped her make lei i sat there and
cleaned her flowers and I just got to
sort of be immersed in her passion of
lei making there's many different styles
of lace I personally specialize in
making awfully how cool a is generally
worn on your head they pull like I'm
wearing mine on my head some people wear
them around their neck and how could
just refers to the traditional style of
making it here we go they have lots of
different materials and them usually in
Hawaii you don't show up to a birthday
party you don't show up to a wedding you
don't show up to a baby shower without a
lei for somebody la represents you you
don't take your lay off because your
mana your spirit is already
of this league I think that's one of the
best ways to say I get from the heart
floral sweet tactile visual and very
special you know that if you got a lei
or if you gift Italy you had a
connection with Hawaii lei and Hawaii is
the ultimate expression of Allah
Hawaiians we have an innate a lost
spirit you know which is a warm
welcoming stay with me eat with me share
with me and I think that is sort of
embodied in LA
you